هذا موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم نقلت وكاله
رويترز عن وسائل اعلام حكوميه سوريه قبل
قليل قولها ان عدوانا اسرائيليا يستهدف
محيط مطار حلب الدوليه
اقتحم عشراته المستوطنين بلده حوار جنوب
نابلس تحت حمايه جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وافاد شهود عيان ان المستوطنين اطلقوا
الرصاص الحيه في الهواء والقوا الحجاره
على سيارات للفلسطينيين على الطريق الرئيس
للبلده
وقد هدمت سلطات الاحتلال تسعه منازل سكنيه
بزعم بنائها دون ترخيص في القدس الشرقيه
والخليل وريحا في الضفه الغربيه
وطلب وزير الامن القوميه
بتنفيذ عمليات هدم منازل لفلسطينيين في
القدس المحتله خلال شهر رمضان القادم
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه ان ايران وافقت على السماح للوكاله
بالمضي قدما في اجراءات المراقبه والتحقق
من الانشطه النوويه كذلك خلال اجتماع مجلس
محافظ الوكاله الذي بدا امس الاثنين في
فيينا
من جهته قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني ان طهران توصلت
لتفاهمات مع الوكاله خلال زياره غروس
الاخيره يمكن ان تمهد لحل القضايا العالقه
في الاثناء يتوجه وزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيلي الى واشنطن في
زياره رسميه لبحث قضايا ابرزها الملف
الايراني والقضيه الفلسطينيه بعد التصعيد
الاخير في الضفه الغربيه
من جانبه قال وزير الدفاع الايراني ان
اسرائيل تلجا لتنفيذ اعمال تخريبيه بعد
تاكد قادتها من عجزهم عن القيام بعمليات
علنيه واضاف ان تهديدات اسرائيل ليست سوى
اوهام وحرب نفسيه وان طهران سوف ترد عليها
متى وحيثما راى ذلك ضروريا
اعرب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
نيدبرايس عن قلق بلاده من تصريحات الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد بشان المهاجرين الافارقه
وحملات الاعتقال التي استهدفتهم في
الاسابيع الماضيه وداع برايس سلطات
التونسيه الى التنسيق مع المنظمات الدوليه
لتنسيق العوده الامنه والطوعيه للمهاجرين
الراغبين بالرجوع الى بلدانهم
هذا وعرب المتحدث باسم الامين العامه
للامم المتحده عن قلق المنظمه الدوليه
ازاء ما وصفه بحمله القمع المتزايده التي
يتعرض لها المهاجرون في تونس واكد دجاريكا
ان الامم المتحده تدين خطاب العنصريه
والكراهيه ضد الاجانب
قال الرئيس البنك الدوليين البنك اوقف
عمله مع تونس بعد تصريحات الرئيس بشان
المهاجرين وفي مذكره موجهه لموظفيه قال ان
البنك اوقف اطار عمل الشراكه مع تونس
مؤقتا وارجع اجتماع مجلسه حتى اشعار اخر
واتهم وزير الخارجيه التونسي نبيل عمار
اطرافا داخليه وخارجيه رفض تسميتها
بافتعاله وتاجيج ما وصفها بالحمله التي
تستهدف بلاده
اوصى الرئيس الاوكراني
والدفاع عن مدينه بخماط المشتعله منذ
الصيف الماضي والليل للسقوط في ايدي الروس
وفق مصادر موسكو
قال وزير الدفاع ان قيمه مدينه باخموت
رمزيه اكثر منها استراتيجيه او عملياتيه
اضاف انه اذا سقطت ضخمه فهذا لا يعني ان
روسيا احدثت تغييرا جوهريا في مجريات
الحرب
قال مؤسس شركه فاجنر العسكريه
من الشرطه العسكريه الروسيه اعاقه وصول
اشخاص انضموا حديثا لقواته الى مركز فاجنر
العسكريه واحذر من انهيار جبهه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]